how's your summer going so far it is
going great
i uh just came from the backstreet boys
98 degrees new kid on the block concert
which was
amazing okay i have to know about this
because i heard about it yes
all these boy bands from the 80s and 90s
combined
but here's the thing they've gotten
older
you're not cool anymore it's like
watching your friend's
dad put on tight pants and a bedazzled
vest
and just hump the air
i felt like i honestly felt assaulted by
one of the guys in 98 degrees
he like air humped so hard he's like
yeah like this just like i was like oh
no
thought i felt like he was violating me
i thought he was gonna get in now
now you said it was amazing but
everything you've described so far
sounds horrible
you know what that's actually the term i
wanted to do it's horrible yeah sorry
i'm glad you straightened that out
there's actually one part in the show
where donnie wahlberg grabs a girl from
the audience and kisses her
but not like a polite kiss like a full
tongue
like oh wow like i felt like that's how
i kissed i got away
i felt like he was infecting her with an
alien virus or something
like her stomach was going to pop open
like a little new kid will pop
out uh so that's how they're made you
know
uh i i just uh yeah it just sounds like
a crazy show what made you go to this
show
my wife my wife and like i realized
she was like we gotta go it'll be so
great their new music is good
i don't know about that i don't know if
their new music exit i know that that
they're in a certain part of the show
they even give up performing their own
music
and just dance to other people's music
like
they just go magic mike style they get
up on pedestals take off their shirts
the guys who don't have the bellies
and then they just start grinding on
these pedestals like other people's
music other people's music that's a
white flag yeah that's that's not good
when you break into somebody else's act
and not even sing along with it you just
play their music
someday that's going to be the second
whole second half of this show is going
to be
andy and i just start dancing to the
bg's for the second half of the show and
just i would watch i think it'll be good
it's we're gonna do it next week